[Music]
despite popular belief historians say
pies were not a feature of the pilgrims
first thanksgiving dinner
but in the years since they've become
the finishing touch at countless holiday
meals
this morning on the dish we head into
the kitchen with baker and food stylist
erin jean mcdowell
her first book 2017's the fearless baker
was one of the new york times best
baking books of the year
and her latest release the book on pie
is the number one best seller in its
category
on amazon
it's a pumpernickel pie crust with
sesame seeds avocados lemon juice and
some chili flakes to get a little spice
double crust chicken pot pie because the
crust is only on the top
that is my favorite apple pie these are
mixed berry hand pies
it is a tomato tart to tan which is an
upside
down puff pastry pie sweet or savory
aaron jean mcdowell lives and breathes
pie what is it about pie that separates
it from all of the desserts well i grew
up
eating a lot of pie so i think that
there's definitely like a big pie making
tradition
in the midwest pies are kind of a unique
thing with this very flaky crust
with a huge array of different fillings
and a huge array of different toppings
and that's why i love them is just
because i've been around them so much
pies were part of her childhood she grew
up making them in her grandmother's
kitchen
my name is erin jean is my middle name
and it's my grandma's name which is why
i use my full name and everything
because she's the one who taught me to
make pie oh
so i always use my full name as a little
homage to her who doesn't love
being in their grandmother's kitchen
it's one of my fondest memories and
that's absolutely one of the places
where i fell in love with baking
she's been perfecting her technique and
recipes ever since
but making a really good pie crust ain't
easy
that's also true and i just don't know
why it's so hard
well i think the number one ingredient
that people forget about
with pie crust is actually their hands
or whatever the tool is that they're
using
because the ingredients are simple in my
pie dough there are four ingredients
flour salt butter and water and ice
water
and ice water yes very good and cold
butter cold butter sometimes i even
put the bowl of flour in the freezer for
a little while before i start mixing
but it's really not so much about the
ingredients it's about the technique
[Music]
did you ever have the discussion with
your gran you know what i'm pretty good
at this
i need to go to high school the
inspiration for going to culinary school
actually came from some other members of
my family
i have three older brothers and two of
them are artists
and i desperately wanted to be an artist
but i
didn't seem to have any natural skill
with pencils or paints or
anything and then one day i came home
from an art class a ceramics class and
my mom was making a cake and she was
using a tool that i had used in the
ceramics studio
and it was like this huge light bulb
moment where i was like
what if food is my medium and so i
started right then and there i was about
15 years old and i started making a
whole bunch of really awful cakes
they were just terrible so mcdowell
decided to get some real-life training
after i got my first job in a bakery i
realized it is an art form
i could really do this the summer after
my senior year when most kids are like
you know
hanging with their friends all the time
i was going to bed at 7 00 pm
so that i could wake up in the middle of
the night and go to work but it was
there that i realized oh my gosh i
really
love this which gave her the confidence
to apply to the famed culinary institute
of america
the first time i went i went with my
parents to tour it
they said that the smile on my face it
was my first time being there and i was
just like
it was it was like meant to be i
couldn't imagine going anywhere else
from the first day i set foot on that
campus
a lot of recipes tell you how to do
something
but i like to know why i'm doing it
since graduation
the 33 year old has become a food
stylist i wrote the book on pie
author and a baking consultant on food
52.
a recipe and cookware site you have two
cookbooks under your belt
what's next i want to just keep teaching
so i love doing these videos i'm trying
to show the mistakes as well as showing
the success oh my god that is brilliant
i just want people to see you know
recipes say but don't over mix it but
what does over mixing look like
what is it because no one knows and then
they over mix it right
i believe the mistakes are what get us
to perfection 100
thanksgiving is my absolute favorite
holiday mainly because it's a great
excuse to make and eat a lot of pie
with so much to be thankful for even in
2020
she won't be able to be with her family
for the holidays
at least not in the traditional sense my
favorite thanksgiving tradition is
actually waking up early
when my mom is baking the rolls and we
eat some of the rolls fresh out of the
oven
slathered with butter before anyone else
has even come over and that's gathering
it with buttons yes
and it's sometimes just her and i or her
and my dad and i
and maybe my brother sharing this moment
before kind of all the craziness
happens and and it's a really special so
what will thanksgiving be like for you
this year well i'm gonna make those
rolls i'll tell you that that's one way
that i can be with them even without
being with them that's what's so amazing
about food
is that you know it's this
it's this incredible source of memory
it's this incredible source of
sustenance
it just gives so much
and look what we have oh my goodness
aaron g mcdowell i'm eating apple pie
and you know we're not going to be
together this thanksgiving so i thought
this was
oh this is so good we can all zoom
together we can zoom together
turkey zoom i'll bring you an apple pie
next now i shouldn't have brought the
pods no
and hashtag delicious know there was
outside here you're right
save some room no one said there would
be pot yeah we did there was going to be
pieces
it's delicious and tangy i love it i
love her and i love what she had to say
about food about the memory it actually
brought tears to my eyes thinking i
wasn't thinking about thanksgiving in
that regard but it is there's so many
memories that go with food like that